and the man who single-handedly got the
Dan Patrick show on in Northern Ireland
rory mcilroy Thank You Rory I appreciate
that very welcome we have a big audience
here in Northern Ireland and we couldn't
have gotten in there without you
very good I'm happy to help do you want
to talk off or I'll let you choose well
I would at all talk whatever you guys
want to talk I'm easy I'm very easy but
you talk off all the time you live golf
all the time
can we talk cars yes we can talk cars
would you rather talk cars than go
sure why not yeah not your favorite car
your last purchase was what laferrari
and your favorite car is laugher what is
it about cars ah as he and Poulter
influence you with course holder has a
little bit his love of Ferraris I've
been to his house a few times and seen
his collection I don't have anywhere
near the collection that he does I sort
of like to diversify my portfolio yeah I
love cars I've loved cars ever since I
was able to drive I've sort of been
through all of them I guess by the time
I was like 21 I'd sort of not been there
done that but I I'd sort of sampled
everything so no I just try and go for
the ones that I really like and keep
hold of them and some of the ones
that'll go up in value and they are
investments some of them - first car you
owned was one a BMW 1-series well that
was your first one yeah really
struggling there really struggling yeah
I know I know
did you buy it or when I didn't it was a
it was a loan from a BMW garage because
at that point I was sort of not well
known in the golf world but I was coming
up and I got a little bit of help so
that was nice when did you know you were
great ah I don't know I sometimes I
still died if I'm great I mean it
depends what you what do you define is
great when did you arrive
when did I arrive when I won my first
major 2011 that was when I felt like I
belonged felt like I was I was here to
do something pretty good
this game do you feel like you join that
fraternity like there you know when you
win a major yeah
like all of a sudden you separate
yourself from the pack that once you're
in that select group yeah a little bit
it's nice to be able to call yourself a
major champion and then for me to get
that second one pretty soon off to the
first one and call yourself a multiple
major champion I think that carries its
own prestige with it as well because
there's you know a lot of guys and I'm
not like I'm not taking anything away
from guys that have won one major and no
majors or whatever but once you go from
one to two feel like you go up a little
level again so I was reading some of the
European media I saw an article that
time is slipping away for Rory to be
great and this was just recently might
have been the Irish Times I mean how do
you deal with the European media as
opposed to the American media yeah I
definitely feel like I get a not a
harder time but there's maybe more
expectation from from your home media or
from the the people that have watched
you for so long growing up well that's
pretty tough at age 28 but time is
running out I know over the hill
Nold but I guess I mean it's all in
context and you think of the guys that
are coming up and coming through Jordan
speith Jean ROM Justin Thomas
all these guys are younger than me and
there are the guys that are now winning
majors and I have them on one in a few
years and I can see where they're trying
to go with it but yeah again I've got a
feel like I have time on my side and
feel like you know the last sort of year
has been a struggle with injuries and
everything but I'm definitely over that
and past that and it teen could be a
really good year for me Rory McIlroy
joining us Dan Patrick show we all took
a bet we placed bets prior to you
showing up how much you could bench
let's go around the room how much Rory
can bench Paulie I would say max out 310
well okay seaton it's gonna go to 90
okay Fritzi 325 325
Wow McLovin 275 275 the most you've ever
done one rep Rory McIlroy is 250 250 Wow
Wow
wait is that the metric system like I
said oh that's man we're disappointed I
I'm sorry to discipline man okay here
was the other thing we've been
practicing our Irish accents I want you
to judge Paul do you want to start now
if we work in Northern Ireland or just
regular Ireland because there's a big
difference remember the last time we had
Rory on and I said you know you the
Patrick Harrington turdy turd and then
he doesn't do dirty turd yeah that's not
it
okay so Northern Ireland Paulie I love
it over the hill enrolled no ferdi okay
oh it's eatin dad a turd Santa me man
PAH
I mean Irish that's very good okay cuz I
speak I speak Gaelic so it's not really
fair with you guys right Fritzi some of
that media criticism so much Blarney
okay how's that wrong yeah
McLovin hello governor no no no no no
just cross the body of water on your
right there sweep your chimney for ya no
that's not that's not good either you've
been watching so much peaky blinders
yeah have you modified your accent I'm
if you go back home
does it get thicker yeah my wife says it
that when I start to talk with my
friends it gets thicker and I start to
talk faster and so it's definitely
neutralized since coming over here and
playing and living here how's your
American accent awesome it is okay Musa
you get like a Southwestern feel like
they'll you know talk like tatertot hey
hey yeah yeah yeah where's the strangest
place that you've been recognized
I'm trying to think of what may not be
strange because you travel the world
yeah yeah it's somewhere where they
don't play golf I mean old area where's
this like if people come up to you block
yeah I don't know strange places to say
little strange places as in like the
bathroom you get that get that a little
bit yeah yeah bathrooms are always a
strange one yeah always try to keep an
eye of peripheral my I feel like over
the past five years my peripheral vision
has got very good most famous person you
play golf with Donald Trump probably at
the minute okay I mean there's not right
now right now yeah yeah probably I would
say so yeah one of the Presidents Bill
Clinton maybe yeah
yeah the Clinton versus Trump if you
were if you're gonna have a Ryder Cup
team and you get to pair you want
Clinton Obama or Trump golf wise golf
[Laughter]
ball would be great yeah is Trump better
than Clinton even worse than tiger and
Phil if I get okay in fairness I think
Trump is probably the best golfer right
of the three how good is he I mean he's
he's alright I mean like presidentially
good yeah yeah I mean what's he gonna
what do you think he would shoot like
legit I think if he played well he could
break Eddie okay
so but I don't know what you know I'd
say yeah somewhere between 80 and 85 I'd
say good [ __ ] anybody make you one
coming for you just go this isn't going
well cuz you're talking about tiger and
and Phil yeah like you you know you know
one name names
no I mean I don't mind I mean not I mean
most of the guys on tour are good and we
see each other every week so there's no
it's just wasted energy to to have these
little niggles with everyone so I I try
to get along but yeah there's some
people that you know I would rather not
be paired with I don't want to name
names but uh I guess for me I've noticed
a big thing and this is a big thing in
golf and you guys are probably seen it
but like the slow players and slow play
and especially someone that plays pretty
quickly because you have to adopt your
game they never took they know they're
never gonna adopt theirs to play quicker
so that the quicker guys always have to
adopt and that that's something that is
a struggle the favorite hole at Pebble
Beach as well seven is such a cool
little hole par three it's a hundred
yards just right there and I mean it's
yeah I think there's a lot of I think
the best part three is in the world are
all under 150 yards yeah and that's
definitely one of them it can be a
pitching wedge to the five iron nerves I
mean this is probably gonna be I mean
the weather looks like it's gonna be
good all week so it'll be a lob wedge or
a sand wedge and you know there's yeah I
remember flying a practice round here
for the US Open a few years ago and
you're hitting a 6-iron in yeah so it
can change dramatically
well good luck this week oh it's always
great that you stopped by and once again
thank you for having me on getting the
cable operators in Northern Ireland to
put the Dan Patrick show on he's Rory
McIlroy we're back after this in the Dan
Patrick show one tip from Rory McIlroy
cutting wise as well
one tip for Morey McIlroy putting wises
what okay so that see I would say get on
your left side a little bit more you're
a little on your right side just sort of
a little more like 6040 okay how's that
yeah that looks good and then what else
and then do you look in front of the
ball do you do is I use a line so I line
the ball up like that but yeah I mean if
I'm trying to be good I'll sort of am
maybe a couple or three inches in front
of the ball and try and pick a little
something like that corresponds where
you want to go
okay so 6040 left side yeah there's a
bad read you didn't happen all right the
last thing okay
yeah where's the last time you caddy for
somebody okay so how's that I didn't get
the tiger thing supposed to go thank you
Dad
thank you yeah but for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]